[Music]
our 5-year-old may be traumatized after
accidentally witnessing my husband and I
having
sex was it boring under the covers
married sex or were youall getting after
it I wish it was the boring under the
[Music]
covers what is up this is John with Dr
John delone show we are so so grateful
that you joined us happy New Year to you
hope you're still hanging on to all of
your New Year's resolutions you're
changing some habits slowly but surely
chipping away at New Life hope you're
doing well if you want to be on this
show give me a buzz at 84469 33291 or go
to John dooney.com
askas and Kelly is out of the building
again good to see you Jenna yes good to
see you how's baby you doing baby is
growing we're at uh 30 weeks now so
starting the countdown very cool man
that's amazing that's awesome very very
cool countdown begins and you're naming
the baby John right uh not necessarily
nope but like mostly nope not at all
actually wow that's not what I was
expecting at all just going to sit here
in silence for a minute cuz well
considering the fact that also my step
brother's name is John that would might
be a little weird or a way to honor both
of us at the same time
I think it's fine wow wonder you
Millennials you and your disregard for
legacy and tradition and honor and love
and care my goodness all right let's go
out to Columbus Ohio and talk to Amanda
what's up
Amanda hey John what up uh not much so
I've got a h pretty big question here I
am okay go for it worried I am worried
that um our 5-year-old may be
traumatized after accidentally
witnessing my husband and I having sex
um I'm worried that there maybe some
negative down dream effects or just
hoping I'm
overreacting okay I gotta paint me the
whole picture here pain tell me the
story okay so my husband and I are super
careful about making sure that our door
is closed and locked but apparently her
ninja skills she snuck into our bedroom
and hid in our closet it wasn't until I
went to the closet to get dressed and
flip the light on and I see her there
with her face buried in her knees so
naturally I go oh my God jump out of the
doorway throw on a robe and asked her
what are you doing in here she
apparently had had a nightmare and had
snuck in there before got the door
closed oh she had a nightmare all right
yeah she had two nightmares concurrent
we call it wow yeah okay um how how
comfortable are you with me asking like
real questions here go for it okay um
and this isn't me being um uh like just
trying to be like I don't know over the
top this is me like asking like for real
questions okay absolutely
um was it boring under the covers
married sex or were youall getting after
it I wish it was the boring under the
[Laughter]
covers oh okay fantastic even better
even better um so and where she was
sitting technically she could have seen
basically
everything lights on or
off uh there was TV light so it was
illuminated yeah she say she didn't see
anything well course of course I mean
1,000% and let's be like what you hear
right
I'm sorry what did she
hear there would have been some sounds
yeah
yeah we're expecting our fourth so I
mean I don't even know what that has to
do with this but that's fantastic oh man
so again I'm not trying to be gratuitous
um I'm trying to paint get a picture of
what this 5-year-old experienced right
what she saw what she heard um all right
so like yelling or anything like that
but I mean it wasn't
silent okay um do y'all I mean was was
there did she hear things that would
have scared her that's the question do
yall talk dirty to each other was there
role playing or was
there you see what I'm saying yeah it I
I don't think there would have been
anything like that okay that was just
baby one and two not three and
four all right so um she leaves you open
the door un like um fully unclothed and
there's your child how old is she five
five um clearly in a like terrified
position
right and you jump back grab a rope then
what happens tell me tell me how you
walked through with her what happened
next so I brought her over to me and
picked her up and just very calmly I was
very careful about like my body language
and tone asked her why what she was
doing in the bedroom and that's when she
said she had had a nightmare and then I
asked her did you did you see anything
she's like no and then I um proceeded to
say well if you did I'm I'm really sorry
if you did that wasn't meant for your
eyes that's something that's for adult
husbands and wives perfect she hasn't
said anything about it it's been a week
but you know I'm worried yeah so okay
you handled that about as perfectly as
you could handle that okay um I'd be
willing to bet
99.999% chance she did see some or all
of of
everything um and again there is a
difference between we're under the
covers and explaining that like she's
seeing like what looks like under the
covers wrestling if you will and in
those kind of situations often what
scares a kid is she sees a different
face on Mom or she sees a different face
on dad that she's never seen before
she's does have a she doesn't have a
psychology she has angry she has joyful
she has frustrated she doesn't have
ecstasy she doesn't have um that there's
just a different face right and so that
often doesn't compute with a kid and can
scare
them then there's explaining oral sex
and then there's explaining oh no
I I like it when fill in the blank right
that's a totally different conversation
and so I think you did the exact right
thing number one kids are going to
absorb your body language and so if
you're not freaking
out oh my God but it's like no no no we
were totally partying and we're married
it's what we supposed to do a it's
awesome B and C you weren't supposed to
see that because that's for adults
that's
grown-ups and so you handled that
perfectly kudos to you high five to you
all right so um did you ever walk in on
your parents not that I remember
no no my my my mind blocked it out all
of it all of it all of it um okay so
what makes you think this is a you've
ruined your child or you're gon to scar
your
kid I don't know I feel like I worked so
hard to try and like put up safeguards
like with using the internet and all
that stuff just to make sure that they
don't accidentally see like
inappropriate or pornographic images and
I feel like I've failed her in that
because she witnessed that okay I think
what the question you're asking is so so
important and so I'm really grateful
like and so I'm laughing cuz I have a
seven-year-old and a
13-year-old and to my
knowledge they haven't I'm I'm just
laughing because God Almighty like the
this can happen to all of this right um
but the question you're asking is really
really an important one okay so number
one you and your
husband rocking on to the break of dawn
in your bedroom in your home is not
pornography MH and I think we have a
habit of dumping all sex into something
elicit is it too is is a 5-year-old too
young to see what she saw absolutely no
question about it but there is a
difference between her mom and dad and
pornography okay and so a you didn't
ruin your
kid your kids's GNA have some stories to
tell make no mistake about that um for
sure like 100% but you didn't ruin
anybody okay okay
um paint me a picture of the
conversation Joel have had with with her
and your other kids about sex before or
is this this the first time uh no so we
were trying to make it like a not
necessarily common conversation but one
that's not so awkward okay um like they
know correct anatonic terms that those
areas of their body are not bad areas of
their body it's just they're for them
and not for other people okay um that
people shouldn't see it people shouldn't
touch it um that sort of thing okay um
so you have done a great job of what I'd
call priming the
conversation I also think that this is
the awkward part where parents wait for
the kid to say something I've heard
parents tell their kids um if you ever
have any questions just come ask me
which is you might as well tell your kid
never ever talk to me about this ever as
long as you live right cuz no kids going
to ask their parents after getting
caught with like looking at pornography
on the computer or getting caught like
hooking up with their boyfriend or
girlfriend or no K parent no kid is GNA
be like all right Dad I'll come ask and
actually no kid's gonna do that and so I
think this is where you have to head
directly into the
awkward and
um I like these along gender roles right
now um I think it
can um
it doesn't have to be but I I I I think
that's a safer way to do it right now
given your home context but I would take
your daughter out and make it something
a kind of a special take take her out
and say all right we have to talk about
the other
night and say I'm not mad in any way
you're you need to not sneak into mom
and dad's room and you know that but I'm
not mad at you at all but it is
important for me to know what you
saw and if she says nothing I promise I
promise
um say it's it's I would I would push a
little bit and see and if she doesn't
want to see I think then if you haven't
explained here's how sex actually
works and um like Daddy's part goes
inside mommy's part this is how this
works um then I would have take that
time to have that conversation there so
you're going to start to give her
language that she may not have yet or
she may have it but not know if it's
okay to say it out loud
and also here's the big thing you're
going to talk about sex and how it works
and how great it is and the importance
of what context it's good and what
context it's not good and more important
than the actual words you're saying is
she's going to totally absorb your body
energy and if you are awkward and
freaked out and scared to death and oh
my gosh I'm terrified to even be having
this conversation she will put a GPS pin
in sex is not okay to talk with mom
about all right right I don't want that
exactly right and also you probably
don't want
to you don't want to explain uh oral sex
to your 5-year-old either right you
don't you don't do that either so none
of this is is like awesome or ideal but
this is our role as parents right
absolutely but the calmer you are the
more you smile the more you laugh the
more you what did you say have you that
kind of thing and then being real clear
about here's the context that's I
think's important for us one last thing
I would add oh so let me stop you there
so tell me is that ringing true does
that feel right um are there yeah I can
totally do that that's not gonna be a
problem okay
um do you believe her that she didn't
see anything or do you think she
did I think that she saw something and
maybe got scared and hit her face okay
all right one question that kids often
feel internally when they catch their
parents having sex is it appears to them
that somebody's getting
hurt and so I think it's important to
say mommy was not getting hurt at all in
fact mommy is really enjoying herself in
a private adult
thing and often that's the fear is
somebody's getting hurt or I don't
understand what's happening here if she
saw more than she saw more and y'all can
kind of dig into that a little bit um
and I wouldn't press it but what I would
do is maybe put a pen in it and circle
back to it in a couple of weeks and then
Circle back to it in a couple of weeks
and um the safer she feels to have a
conversation about it then it will
hopefully it will it'll eventually
emerge there you may also want to give
her just a small bottle of bleach so she
can rinse out her
eyeballs I know I feel so
bad oh my gosh hey here's the last thing
here's the last thing um I would it so
I'm about to talk about Santa Claus and
so if you have kids listening to the
show you might want to Shield their eyes
I mean their ears from what I'm about to
say three two one all right so I
recently had a conversation with my
daughter about um I need to have a
grownup conversation with you and it has
to be a private conversation that I'm
having with you and we explained to her
for several reasons that Santa Claus is
not real and walked her through it and I
every step along the way I told her
where having a grown-up conversation and
this is not for you to share with your
friends MH and I told her about a time
when I was a kid and I blew it I told a
bunch of my friends that Santa wasn't
real and I actually hurt people and I
didn't mean to I was just trying to be
the know-it-all idiot kid and so I told
her that she can really hurt people and
ruin some of the magic if she tells her
friends so this is just private between
us and she really took that to heart
and so I would reiterate with your
daughter that this is private things
this is not to be shared with her
friends at
school okay and remind her she's only
allowed to have secrets with you with
Dad or with the doctor that's it that's
the only people she can have secrets
with and but this one is going to be a
private thing between you and Dad and um
her okay is that fair yeah that sounds
super straightforward I can do that and
I don't mean this in a in a erotic
way so I would say like I I would like
to I would love for you to call back and
walk me through how you and your husband
the next time y'all are about to hook up
that you start in one corner of your of
your bedroom suite and just go every
square inch I can't can't I'm scanning
the whole house
now I can only only imagine that's how
that's playing out that will never
happen again in I have anything to do
with it 100% will hey what about your
husband what did he have to say about
it oh he was slightly mortified but he
figured he's like oh she'll be fine
yeah on behalf of mental health
practitioners around the country we
thank you for your future business
Amanda um both of you you may want to
make a small account just on the side
just a high yield savings account you
can put a little money in because she's
going to need to go to counseling and
talk about this but um not really I I
don't I think you you you've done such a
great job
norming talking about body parts norming
what's okay and what's not okay
particularly
norming
grown-ups in a married loving
relationship can do this right and it's
okay A and you weren't supposed to see
this um this wasn't for kids to see so
um you did great hey if you are watching
this um or listening and you haven't had
the body part conversation there's a
great book by Julie
Federico it's called some parts are not
for sharing some parts are not for
sharing by Julie
federo um it's a tiny tiny little book
but it is a fabulous book to walk
through um really really excellent
excellent book
um best of luck to you Amanda and
everybody check your
rooms and on behalf of your kids lock
the door we'll be right
back hey I've got some great news for
you you get to choose whatever you do
good or bad moving forward the choice is
yours and when you're intentional about
making good choices over time they
become Healthy Habits Like choosing to
slow down and make time for a daily
practice of prayer and meditation one
thing that helps me every single day is
hallow
hallow is the number one Prayer app in
the world on planet Earth and they're
giving you three free months to get
started and people always say you got to
meditate you got to pray you got to have
a spiritual life and for many of us we
don't even know what that means we don't
even know where to start that's where
hallow steps in three free months to
prioritize your mental health your
spiritual health and be intentional
about finding peace through calming
music the lowii station that I love
guided prayers meditations and more and
hallow isn't just Catholic you can
tailor the content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to journaling Hall makes it easy
to practice mindfulness build a deeper
more meaningful spiritual life to figure
out what you even believe in the first
place and choose peace and remember Hall
is giving you 90 days free imagine the
peaceful habits you can establish in 90
days go to hall.com dealone toay and
follow the simple prompt to start your
free 90day trial that's hall.com
dealone all right we are back and what
Jenna okay so Andrew made a good point
um at the end of that call you said now
if for any children listening we're
about to talk about Santa yeah children
should not have been listening anyways
just GNA point that out just clarifying
that's actually a fair point
all Hey listen all I know is this is in
one of the questions for humans Dex the
question for is when did you find out
Santa was a lie and one of my friends
his kid grabbed that deck and was crying
and that person works here with us and
the kid and they went running in like
what's wrong baby and was holding this
card and so he just texted me a picture
of the card and was like way to go
deloney way to go so I now talk to your
kids about sex but but for God's sakes
be trigger alert when it comes to
talking about Santa Claus gez aise and
by the way while I'm here very few
things do I get more hate on the
internet about
[Music]
than this idea of don't lie to your kids
telling your kids that Santa Israel is
not a lie it's letting them participate
in the magic of of of a cultural myth
don't take that from your kids like in
the name of I'm never gonna lie to my
kids it's not gez Louise geez Louise I
ain't going to do fake snow I ain't
going to lie to my kids I'm not going to
let them play on As turf football that's
I'm not going to lie to my kids that
ain't real grass let him participate
it's fun it's fun the world has taken
enough Magic from our children at least
give them Santa Claus for a few years
it's a blast all right let's go out to
Fort Collins Colorado and talk to Brian
what's up
Brian hey Dr deloney glad to i' be
talking with you glad to talk to you man
what's up uh okay 7 18-year-old
daughter uh graduating in May she has
been dating her boyfriend for a year and
a half he's also 17 he's also graduating
in may they want to get married oh boy
next August they'll be
18 by then they are both planning to go
to college different schools same
area and uh my wife and have a lot of
challenges as you might imagine around
this on your behalf I do too so
got it yeah yeah thanks um one one of
the many questions we have
is uh how much we ought to be paying for
an actual wedding ceremony next
summer I have I have an immediate
response to that and before I give it I
want to talk through like how have your
conversations been up until
now like how is this Con how is this
this conversation addressed why do they
want to get married so young what are
they so what's the hurry like walk me
through that yeah right um conversations
have been plentiful okay I think they've
been most everything's on the table okay
um honesty around this is a
struggle uh I am scared yeah just shared
that with both of them the other night I
said I'm not angry I'm scared and that's
what you're seeing yeah uh for your
future because our our goal is for them
to be successful there you go they're
going to get married and we think um
there's maybe a better time in life to
get to start with better odds if I will
sure uh yeah so the conversations have
have been good it's been back and forth
it's starting to feel a little bit like
it's a compromise or
negotiation with the timeline um and
money's coming up as you might imagine
they they don't have
any and they're not going to have any
being in school full-time
right uh
um man
[Music]
um I I don't need to run through the the
data with you you know statistically
this is going to be tough one yes um I
think right now there's there's kind of
a two-prong approach number one is the
one you're taking which I absolutely
think is right you're meeting with both
of them both both of them right and um
saying hey we're just worried about you
by the way before I keep going what does
his parents have to say about
this uh schools a priority uh for sure
and seemingly less bothered by the
timeline
okay um as long as the plan for
education and you know succeeding there
continue uh I think we have different
Outlook s on overall financial
support uh for them um and those have
been separated into here you know what's
School financial support and what is
you're deciding to get married at 18
financial support look like like a
living right surviving have they made a
budget have you sat down with them to
make a budget yet y yep yeah working on
it now and also um handing our daughter
some expectations starting in January so
while she s at home while she adults and
moves toward that she feels what it's
like to pay more of her share to start
paying her car insurance in monthly
installments some of that kind of thing
that's been a point of contention but
it's what we've done with our other kids
we've just had to accelerate this a bit
because she's wanting to get married at
18 right our other two two older ones
didn't do that that our La we had a
different timeline so we're having to
adjust those things as parents which is
got to tell you it's been trick ick this
is some of the hardest parenting we've
done yeah I mean it sounds like you're
navigating it as well as you can I think
a gift to them so let's take marriage
off the table let's take something
statistically improbable with a high
likelihood you get hurt potentially
forever and a small sliver of success
let's say your 17-year-old comes to you
and says I'm a worldclass athlete and
I'm going to the NFL directly from high
school and I know there's some laws and
rules about that but let's just pretend
they could do that uh not laws but
there's some regulations and NFL
guidelines and things but let's say they
could just do
that you would be failing your kid if
you didn't say
okay the weight room just got real real
serious like like uh we've been taking
it easy on you because you're GNA have
to get real strong to head out onto that
field the workouts are going to get
heavy the responsibilities are going to
right so I think it's important to look
at this as like okay if this is
happening we're going to prepare you in
the best way possible and part of that
is letting this 17-year-old know if
you're going to make adult decisions
it's going to come with adult um
responsibilities and those
responsibilities have consequences to
them so I would be failing you as your
dad if I didn't let you have some a
taste of that some practice of that
before you make this big decision here
and by the way
um is she's already thinking about being
18 she's still 17 she still lives in
your house
right right six more months yeah how how
many six more months before 18
y golly can I tell you I've I this is
not the right answer but I have a real
thing in my gut right now
that well I think this would be not
probably wise
parenting you're you're hearing me go
through this in real time okay and I've
got several competing things in my mind
I'm just going to speak them out loud is
that okay please thank you thing number
one is if you got six
months part of me would want to go
scorched
Earth you can't have contact with this
person I'm cutting off your phone like
you still live in my house and if you
want to leave after six months knock
your lights out and I know the Hipster
cool thing to do would be like well you
just got to accept it so let's just ride
this out and I part of me says No you're
17 you're my child and I see the semi
coming down the road at you and I'm
going to shove you out of the way with
two hands and you may even break your
arm when you fall but I'm going to
protect you from that
car so part of me in my gut says go
scorched Earth and then the other part
of me knows after working with young
people for 20 years that you have a
strong possibility you're going to lose
your kid doing
that right um and so I I so I'm I'm
thinking this out loud in real ter time
and I want people to have a picture of
what it what it looks like to think
about something in real time so I'm
going to say this thing that my gut says
to do but probably is not the right
thing the second thing I think is is
right you slowly turn on the turning up
the weight of adulthood here's what this
looks like I think the question you're
going to have to ask yourself you and
your wife are going to have to ask is
the or what
statement because if next August comes
and you guys have put some hoops that
they think that they'll go
through um because I've heard it said
when you get married then you lose
College I'm not paying for college
anymore you're grown up I'm not paying
for your apartment I'm not paying for
any of this stuff you're married now I
get that and you also so know as well as
I do what happens when an 18-year-old
just gets let out into the world their
opportunity their need to go make money
can turn into some really bad choices
very very
quickly um and so part of me
says I'm gonna put hoop a I'm gonna put
hoop B like as long as you're my you got
to work full-time because you think
marriage is going to be going on dates
and stuff it's a lot of work because
yall going to have to afford X Y and Z
so when you get done for school you're
going to have a full-time job and you
might be able to see him on the weekends
but that's kind of married life too and
so let's just get after it and y'all
come up with a dollar amount you come up
with a support amount you come up with
grades amount things like
that but if I'm if I'm speaking honestly
and openly I
think if they want to get married at 18
I have to make a choice me and my wife
have to make a choice is is do we want
to be a part of these photographs or
not and I will probably choose to stand
by my kid side and give the best chance
of
success but that doesn't mean I'm going
to throw $150,000
wedding yeah thank you yeah we really
agree with you I'm so glad that we're
chatting because several things you've
said are have been either Intuition or
we've already started talking and it is
that it's a dance right to to support
and love our kids and if I wanted to be
successful of locking them out and not
joining them is is the wrong recipe for
me personally yeah I'll I'll be by their
side it's the wrong it's the it's wrong
across the board and I can't tell you
how I can't count I cannot count the
number of parents who their kid um who
came to me when I was working at the
University and sat down this kids are 18
to 25 year olds and said Mom I'm
pregnant mom I'm gay Mom I'm dropping
out of school mom I can't be a lawyer
because I flunked out and how many moms
and dads have come back and said I would
do anything to have my initial reaction
back and have it be anything other than
I love you and I'm here and so I think
your intuition is right I think it's
psychologically accurate I think it's
philosophically accurate I think it's
theologically for my my particular
beliefs I know what yours are but mine
mine it's
accurate I also think just signing up
for a oh this is so great as though they
were 26 and they've graduated college
and they have a financial they have
Financial Security that's not wise
either because you're setting them up
for a fairy tale that's going to come to
a crashing halt
right yeah I I think that's right on um
doctor is is finding that balance of
real World expectations a little bit of
a I'm going to say a sting I don't even
mean it to sting but a reality check
over the next several months of what
this looks like and then after that it's
it's tuition help but then it's
emotional support right um I do it
really is because I I don't I by the way
I didn't budget the next three years for
this dad doesn't pivot either yeah and
and I also
um I think now's a beautiful moment to
say to your future potential and now
let's be honest um when I was 17 I
signed a 100% track track scholarship at
a university out of state
100% I um had the season of my life and
then I dropped the Baton in first place
and I ended up losing the district trap
meet for our team by one point for the
first loss in a decade I then didn't
ever want to step on a track again I met
a girl at a summer camp and moved states
to pay to go to college I ended up with
a small scholarship and join their track
team a little bit later but all that to
say is who knows what happens in the
life of an 18-year-old the next you know
year from now
right but um it can sure feel heavy
right this second right um so I want to
I want to hold that a little bit Loosely
but also prepping for hey this is what
this is going to look like we didn't
plan for this we didn't prep for this
and so you're not going to get $150,000
we're not going to blow the the top off
here and by the way this is my money you
don't have an entitled right to it
son-in-law my expectation for the man
who marries my daughter is that we meet
for breakfast once a week that's
happening and I think you begin to treat
him like the man he thinks he already
is if you're going to marry my daughter
you will meet with me once a week but
here's book number one how to be a good
and you find a great book about being a
man and provision and expectation and
being a good partner I think you you set
the stage for
him and there is the daughter part and
there's the raising the daughter part
and she's my kid but I think there's a
looking across the table at him and
letting him feel the
expectation my father-in-law did that in
a we lived in different cities but he
did it in a unique way that I felt a
responsibility to take care of his
daughter and by the way she's smarter
than me she was making more money than
me at the time so that's not what I mean
by taking care of
but I meant you better be a person of
fidelity and you better show
up yeah I love that idea he asked um for
her hand last week
okay um and I brought something like you
set up so you just affirmed my my gut on
that and that's something that I I think
he's going to say yes to I think he
would get
that and and the thing you didn't say
would which really is important to me is
it begins creating a space for me to
love my new son there you go and I I
wasn't going to say it because I wanted
you to have to back into it but this is
going to be for you too because at some
point your kids you're I
mean the hardest thing in the world I
say this all the time the hardest thing
in the world is when you love another
adult and that adult is in your life and
they're making decisions that you
project out are not going to be good for
them whether it's our our elderly
parents the way they spend their money
or whether it's our our siblings not
saving money or doing something doing
you know messing with substance abuses
or 18-year-old kids deciding hey we're
going to go to a really adult thing
without any understanding of what's
coming
next yeah but you making peace with it
over time I don't know it's you making
peace with it but I think it's maybe you
raising him up and he doesn't sound like
he has a dad that's doing that I love
the idea with you saying I'm not
prepared to give you my blessing but I'm
going to and you sit down and you meet
him and and dude I would challenge you
to
to give him as direct eye contact as you
could possibly
muster and I don't mean this in a piss
and contest or like an old Texas mail
kind of thing I mean he needs to
understand the weight of what he is
taking on he is
asking to join with your
daughter and for him to become the most
important man in your life and you are
not just going to open your hand to that
uh willy-nilly right
and so I think there's something about
saying I'm not prepared to give you my
blessing but you can earn
it and I think you're a good young man
but from this point forward and I put a
date on it June
1st if you meet me for a book study you
show up and help me with X Y and Z you
show me that you know what a budget is
um you show me that you can honor my
daughter in XYZ when you present how
yall going to manage College costs and
without taking a bunch of stupid student
loans out you can manage housing you can
manage some these things then absolutely
but just cuz you love her and you're 17
that's not enough for my
blessing love that yeah I really love
that and then helps us my wife and I
pivot it's really been about our
daughter as you might imagine and trying
to figure all that out but I think it's
a her and scenario it really is about
him now it's it's game on and and it you
know foundationally it's it's still
about what do we need to do to give them
the best chance success against those
odds that you mentioned which are very
searchable and findable by the way
divorce rates in America so it really it
really feels aligned with our value set
um and I think I think people are going
to listen to this by the way and I want
to be real clear I had some coaches in
my life I've had some
mentors that
have challenged
me on an athletic field have challenged
me across a table have challenged me
nose to nose and it was never me verse
them it was them with me calling me to
something bigger than I even knew I was
entering
into and so I think you saying I'm not
ready to give you my blessing yet
because just because you like my
daughter by the way 17-year-old you
don't even have a clue as to what love
is you bury a grandparent or a parent
you go through a pregnancy you go
through lot now we're talking love but
at 17 you like my daughter a lot I get
that so you're not ready for my blessing
here's a road map to get it game on and
that is not you challenging him and and
sitting on the front porch with a
shotgun that's stupid but that is you
eye to eye nose to nose chest to chest
calling him
in right and that's a totally different
ball
game and I think being very very clear
with your daughter here is the dollar
amount that we can afford we have not
prepped or planned for this and we don't
have period here is what your next six
months will look like being a
17-year-old in our home with the
intention of swan diving into adulthood
here you go if you don't meet this I'll
walk with you to the courthouse I'll
walk with you down the aisle but my
dollars and cents are not going to
participate in
this thank you for that and so we're
about to hand her in writing because she
requested that so that was smart you
know the money part yep and what that
allows the six or eight months allows is
a chance for that to be a learning but
also a a reconsideration of choices if
she and he want to reconsider timelines
yeah and tell them we're done we're done
with that fight you know if that's it
that's it but here's here's how we're
going to show up and we love you and and
so may maybe there's some influence with
that also I wouldn't be opposed to
saying and you wait till 21 and col and
youall walk youall have your diplomas in
hand here here's the number I'm going to
put on the table for your
wedding and by the way if that sways
them if that sways them that tells you
how they're they're IM their maturity
level
right yeah yeah we' we've wondered about
that a little bit and you know carrot
stick mentality and it feels like really
close to manipulation here's the beauty
want to manipulate a good outcome it's
your money do whatever you want to with
it yeah you don't owe anybody
anything period there's millions and
millions and millions and millions of
dads in your situation that would love
to help their 25-year-old their 35y old
daughters came married they have no
money and so the fact that you have some
doesn't mean she's entitled to
it I don't think it's manipulation at
all I think it's very very
wise to say I will be able to I will Dad
because I live by a budget your mom and
I will be able to put $7,500 towards a
ceremony in August
period if you borrow a penny more on a
credit card you will lose access to all
$7,500 period I'm not going to
participate and you starting an already
very challenging relational Endeavor in
the whole financially I'm not I can't
support that I'll be there I'll stand by
you but I can't watch you start off in
the hole like that you can do whatever
you want and then say if you wait till
you're 21 and both of y'all have your
degrees I'll make it
50,000 and maybe calls your bluff dude
you got to save some money over the next
four or five years
right yeah yeah you're you're a mind
reader too aren't you but but listen
statistically speaking they won't make
it through college
dating and if they do good for them good
for them
yeah but I don't want you I don't want
you to ever succeed um I don't want you
to ever lose lose sight of this is our
money
and never let her know like always let
her know I will be it any Courthouse you
go to get me I'll be wherever you are my
participation in that though is going to
vary based on what I believe is your
ability to pull this thing
off got it and those are two separate
things is that fair that's fair will you
call me and let me know how it
goes yeah we will certainly try I love I
I love in fact I've never thought of
this and I think I'm going to I'm going
to try to minute he may tell me to go
pound Sam but I love the idea of
um somebody comes
to marry you know let's say some guy
wants to marry my daughter and he asked
for my blessing I love the idea of
saying uh you and I are going to read
this book together first and we're going
to meet over breakfast or whatever and
if you live in another state then I'm
going to fly out there I'm going to meet
with you this is that important to me I
want you to feel how important my
daughter is and if I can't afford a
plane ticket at that time I'm going to
drive across the country and you and I
are going to sit in a cafe for a while
and I'm going to ask you questions about
love and Fidelity and your pornography
use and I'm going to ask you questions
about uh budgets and perspective um uh
education and perspective work careers
I'm going to ask you the questions that
probably nobody asked you and there's
not going to be perfect answers to them
but I want you to know what I expect of
myself what I'm going to expect of the
person who marries my child my child can
marry whoever she wants to can't know
anything about that but if you want my
blessing that's on
me that's on me blessings to you good
man I'll be thinking about you
guys hey quick
lesson stand by your kids especially
when it's hard Stand by Your Kids we'll
be right
back this episode is sponsored by better
help hey it's delone last year I came to
an inflection point I was exercising
regularly I was disciplined in my diet I
was getting regular blood work done and
I was working hard on my marriage I was
doing all the right things but I had not
dealt with old traumas and old stories
that were negatively impacting my
marriage my relationship with my kids my
work and me I'm the expert I teach
others what to do but I was slowly piece
by piece falling apart so I swallowed my
pride and with the encouragement of my
family and friends I reached out to a
therapist and started seeking true deep
healing a year later I'm a radically
different man all for the better and I
know finding a therapist in your local
community can be almost impossible or if
you do find one it's so expensive you
can't afford to go even if you wanted to
and that's why I love the work
betterhelp is doing in the world
betterhelp is online therapy with real
license therapist who are available on
your schedule when you contact better
help you will fill out a short
questionnaire and and they will match
you with the licensed therapist plus you
can switch therapist at any time for no
extra charge you've been working so so
hard and now it's time to get to the
root of your pain for permanent
extraordinary life change visit
betterhelp.com delonay to get 10% off
your first month that's betterhelp
hp.com
delone hey what's up we are back um we
have a very special segment here I asked
my friend George camel who's got a new
book coming out about finance and the
chaos and the nonsense that we're seeing
all over the place about it's the end of
time and the Dollar's going away and you
should have a side hustle oh you
probably should have a side Hustle but
you should have a passive in just all
the stupid stuff so I asked my friend
George it's like hey man come on to the
show with me and a I want to introduce
you to our gang but B I want to behind
the curtains look at you the author of
this thing what in the world is
happening with their money and by the
way George is somebody that uh I call on
the weekends and I'll say hey man I'm
about to move this money over here what
do you think about this fund and he'll
say yeah absolutely do that or don't do
that so he's somebody that I trust with
me and my family's money so I'm excited
to have him on we're gonna just do a
segment with him and uh I think you're
going to get a ton of value and he's
hilarious and he loves telling everybody
that we're best friends and we are not
just kidding we kind of are not really
not even close but we did go to the
blink182 show and had to push his Tesla
down the highway when it ran out of bad
please welcome George
camel what's up man hey thanks for
having me on it's good this is the first
time for me I'm kind of nervous I've
never been on the John deloney show
we've done a lot together but not in
your territory why why does it make you
nervous uh I just feel like I'm not in
control uh that's probably a whenever we
do things see someone for that we try
I've been telling you for a while you
should
um man yeah I guess you've never you
never been on ever no you never invited
me I didn't want to remind you here but
now better time no better time than the
present but it's an honor I'm a big fan
and it's nice to be like inside of the
show you're not a fan you never listen
to my show one time I listen you've
never listened one time it's fine like
we walk together you hear me run my
mouth all the time but I usually I need
to watch Comedy to make you know what I
mean I'm looking for
uppers sometimes the show is heavy can
be a little and we take enough of that
on the Ramy show together so I get my
Dosey I get my dose of my dowery yeah
but I I do I do love gift George is a
gift she just had a baby yes first kid
tell me about it how's it been it's been
hard I will say that harder than I
thought it would be Whitney had a really
hard pregnancy and the delivery was
great and the baby's healthy that was
all great but then she got mastitis and
that turns into scarlet fever which I
didn't know existed in today's world and
that turned into an abscess and like a
minor surgery and then the baby got the
tongue tie thing and so there was always
just another like hard thing yeah in an
already hard season where you're like
not sleeping you're in kind of teammate
mode instead of marriage mode it's just
survival mode yeah I was like did you
get the you get the hatchet I'll get the
roope you get the dogs I'll get the baby
who's dropping the you know what I mean
it's just a lot of logistics and not a
lot of connection uh and in between
there's some really sweet moments you
know with the baby and all that but it
has been dramatically more difficult
than I thought and so I have a newfound
respect for parents I used to like dog
parents and be like you know me I'd be
like I'm a dog Dad I know how hard it is
and I I ate I wasn't gonna say that you
and I have had that conversation you're
like John I've got I've got two French
Bulldogs yeah God fed me some Humble Pie
you're in the middle of um you're
releasing your first book which is chaos
right and you're hosting your own show
and two other shows right so I mean
life's bananas right um You and I are
heading off on a speaking event coming
up like so it's it's it would be chaotic
for any person on the planet then you
throw a newborn in there and then you
throw a very difficult first few months
with the health with your wife all the C
also it goes with that um there's
something
about I don't feel like anything I don't
feel at all I'm just going to keep doing
the next right thing I'm going to do
this thing I'm G to make sure I fill in
the blank I'm going to make sure I
exercise which I know you don't do I'm
going to make sure I do this which what
but I'm going to keep doing those things
and I'm going to March along even though
I don't feel like it and well now is the
time where it's easiest to veg out and
stare at the screens and play a stupid
game on your phone instead of doing the
hard thing like you about the daily
choices the worst
yeah yeah like if I had slept good maybe
I would work out today John but I didn't
sleep good so therefore you know what I
mean just yeah doing it out of
discipline and sheer habit is just so
hard wor but it's on the other side your
your daughter will wake up at one years
old or nine months and she'll look at
you and then you'll have yeah that's
probably a good way to think of it
you're going to be she's going to be one
regardless regardless and the choice you
get to make is how will I have shown up
for her when she turns one when when
that light bulb comes on and it comes on
before one but when that light bulb
comes
on will I be all in or will I be a ghost
of who I was shell of who I used to be
right well truthfully that's been the
biggest struggle in our marriage right
now is Whitney being like hey look her
in the eyes like be present with her
don't veg out on your phone while
feeding you know what I mean that's been
difficult for me after a long day of
work and you just want you know you want
a veg out but you're like I have I need
to connect with this baby like that's
what's important to me yeah I know I
should do it but my brain is is occupado
yeah or I don't know how right it's it's
a tool set it's hard I I'm used to
having conversation let's have some Wht
and banter with a baby you know I'm
making sounds I'm singing I'm doing all
the things I know how to do to see what
she reacts to which is fun so you've got
a you sat down in a room over the last
year and wrote a
book about
what well it was a tough task to write a
money book at Ramsey salute sols there's
this elephant in the room um you know
big shoes to fill when you have The
Total Money Makeover the bestelling
personal finance book of all time and
you're like I'm going to write something
different and better something you know
what I mean like have big shoes to fill
cuz the feet are still in those shoes
exactly it's still sold in the same book
and so my goal was not to like rewrite
The Total Money Makeover the goal was to
write a book that feels like I'm
speaking to everyone in current times of
like this is what the current state of
personal finance is here's the real
problems America's facing here's why
people are saying they can't get ahead
and here's what I know to be true and so
it was a lot of you know I start with my
story of how I started broke with my I
didn't come from money my parents were
immigrants I was $40,000 in debt and
over a decade of just hard work and
following a proven plan my wife and I
are now net worth Millionaires and it's
not to brag it's to say if an average
George can do it you can too but here's
what it takes the gap between financial
peace between Financial stress and
financial peace is littered with myths
and distractions and traps and noise so
my goal was to cut through all of that
and tell people the truth about the
financial system designed to keep them
broke so the truth about credit scores
and credit cards and student loans and
auto loans and mortgage traps and
investing traps and marketing and
consumerism so that they can break free
from this Matrix that they find
themselves in and some for a lot of
people become self-aware for the first
time that they're even in this Matrix
that's like this is a simulation bro you
got you can opt out and they go what do
you mean I don't have need I don't need
a credit
that's jarring to a lot of people and so
I walk it very carefully because I know
what I'm saying is sounds insane to
someone who been in it their whole life
like I was but to deprogram that to
break free from that and achieve all of
your financial goals and become the
person you want to be and to give the
way you want to give that's what the
book's all about it's not really about
the money we have to talk about money so
we can stop talking about money gotcha
gotcha well H how do
you I feel like there's two different
competing anxieties here here the
anxiety that you and I talk about all
the time which is your body knows that
you owe somebody money they're your
master they own you right
and like if you don't do X Y or Z they
take your house they take your car they
take your food and your body knows I'm
not safe in that situation regardless of
how good the deal is there's also this
competing anxiety which is this inner
desire to connect other people to be a
part of a tribe and the entire culture
says if you don't have a new car we you
and I were in a conversation the other
day with somebody like well what do you
want me to get a car with a 100,000
miles on it and we're like we both have
that yeah what are you talking about and
it was like you're not St that guy
wasn't stupid a guy was an entitled that
guy believed a story that he'd been told
which is if you have a car that has more
than a 100,000 miles you are being
unsafe to you and your family right if
you don't have a house with every kid
with their own room and their own
bathroom you're f failing your
children so I I I have to compete here
right one of these is all right I know
my body needs safety the other is I
don't want to be the only one right I
don't want to be the only person not
doing these things what do you tell
somebody that says I I I can't operate
outside of this world well number one
are they open to new information because
if they're not it's it's a pointless
conversation there you go so you have to
go like hey my way isn't working I'm
curious to know how this way works
because that sounds more peaceful the
goal of this book when it comes to
helping people avoid some of those traps
and I point out the Three Stooges of
wealth building is what I call it but I
think it applies in life I'm sure this
applies to mental health Pride fear and
greed those are the three traps I find
when people are trying to build wealth
but also when it comes to personal
finance they go yeah but I'm smarter
than that I'm going to be the guy who
pays off the credit card every month and
doesn't pay interest great the credit
the credit card company loves that you
believe that that's you winning is that
you're not paying interest and that
somehow your life is going to be great
and you're going to build wealth uh fear
is a big one uh fear there's a scarcity
mindset that we see a lot of people I
never had money so I need to keep
stacking even when you're doing well
there's like this NeverEnding Chase for
the gold poost has kept moving well we
have a million but really we need 2
million now because we factor in
inflation so we need four million when
you and so it never ends there never
stops yeah yeah and then you have greed
which is I want to make a million
dollars in the next five years and if I
don't and crypto is the answer because I
can't wait for a mutual fund to grow in
a retirement account and so there's this
element of I can do it faster and I'm
smarter and pride fear and greed I found
is what causes people to fall right on
their face and it's one of the reasons
we have to have the nice car because our
can't swallow your pride and drive a
beater next to your cooworker who's
leasing the luxury vehicle it's
embarrassing that's the lease is making
the car company very wealthy and they
want you to think it's I I just bought a
car with cash and the finance office
called me and they're like we're really
concerned Why aren't you financing this
she was like well you should lease it
that's that's what I do it's the smart
way to do it I'm like I don't know how
to tell you this like I had to be like
listen I host a show where I tell people
not to lease cars that it's the
stupidest way and so I in all the
kindness but it just made me remember
how how much work we have to do to
untrain people's brains to go like there
is a different way and there's a better
way there's just so much pain out there
and we take the brunt of the calls where
like life didn't happen the way it
looked on paper yeah like well if I do
this deal on Airbnb I'm going to make so
much money and they call and they go
like we can't afford the payment and the
Tenant screwed up our house and the car
is getting repoed and we're on the other
end trying to help them pick up the
pieces and it's one of the reasons we're
just like debt equals risk less debt
equals less risk don't owe anyone money
your life's probably going to be less
stressful the the hardest challenge I
think is that I wrestle with in the
conversations we have about money is
when I talk to
somebody most of the people people we
talk to have never been on the other
side so I I've been to your house and
um you have a very very nice home in an
extraordinary neighborhood and you could
go to the bank today and probably
qualify for four or five x the home
you're in right now does that weigh on
you at
all no and I think it reminds me of uh
Dave was on our friend Graham Stefan
show and they asked him like if you
could borrow a million dollars in
guarantee that you would get aund this
much return would you and Dave was like
no they're like why we just told you
you're guaranteed to make this money and
he was like I don't borrow money and it
was such a like mic drop you know bad a
moment of Dave just being like I
actually live by a set of values and
principles MH to where I'm not star eyed
but what by what could be and what the
bank could give me and what investments
could make he's at peace with where he's
at and so confident in his plan to build
wealth that nothing could sway him and
to me that is like in invincibility and
so that's what I feel being anchored
into a value yeah on a much smaller
scale because my wealth is minuscule
compared to Dave Ramsey's but there's
such an amazing feeling going like my
next home I'm sure we'll move one day
into a bigger nicer home maybe we're
going to pay cash for it yeah and that
means it's not going to be a home that
is 4X what we cuz it's going to take a
while to do that with at the speed of
cash but well I will have is peace and
the muscle to save to where I'm like if
we need to save for anything it's not
going to be a problem like saving for a
$20,000 vacation or like saf for pay
someone's adoption fees it's just going
to be another little goal we go yeah we
know how to do that but someone who's
never done that they can't fathom even
saving up $10,000 to pay for a car what
they can fathom is paying $400 a month
for the car payment so it's it's a shift
mentally you got to make you host
multiple shows you're a public figure
you travel the country speaking at
events all over the the place
um and this morning I had to run to
Walmart to get something and talk to the
person who's stocking shelves in the
morning they're like that's cute bro
like cool like P off your card P off
your house real cool um I work at
Walmart because I have to and my dad
left this happened this happened this is
the job I could get I make $18 an hour
um and I'm really grateful to have it
this kind of book works for y'all um I
appreciate it man but I'm trying to make
groceries and I got to get a car like
talk to that guy well I have deep
empathy for those that
feel like there's a certain kind of
person that can get ahead with money and
it's not me cuz I remember feeling that
way I thought you were born into wealth
or you just never have it yeah and
wealth is a very generic term to me
wealth just is is freedom yeah do you
have options do you have margin in your
life that's a good point cuz wealth to
me means more than I've got right now
you know what I mean because I'm always
chasing a feeling wealth to the person
at Walmart is if I could make $20 an
hour it would blow my mind yeah and the
gold post always moves when you make 20
it's like wealth is now 25 an hour it's
it's always more than I got instead of
saying no I'm I'm at peace yeah that's
good so the hard thing for those people
out there who feel like this isn't for
me this plan that's nice but I'm too
broke for this or I'm too wealthy for
this there's this like everyone says
this is not for me the day you realize
you're not special in the best way yeah
yes you're uniquely made by by the
Creator but I'm not special as far as
this plan not working for me to math to
math and so here's the the best thing I
can say to that person is that it's not
all your fault but it's your
responsibility okay and that's a tough
pill to swallow not by your hand but in
your lap yes and so in parentheses not
all your fault we have to own the
choices that we've made that have got us
here uh even if those choices are I saw
my mom and dad handle money the wrong
way and I fell for that I thought my
parents were going to pay for college
and it turned out to be student loans in
my name we hear those stories all the
time but the decision you have to make
is I have agency and autonomy over my
life most people feel like life is just
happening to me and I got to do whatever
the lenders say and I got to do whatever
my boss says but when you realize I have
control not just when it comes to like
what I do with that paycheck but what
career path I choose and how much effort
I'm going to put in and what
opportunities I say yes or no to and the
decisions I make or don't make when it
comes to those dollars and who I decide
to hang out with when you start to
control those inputs you get this little
thing called hope where you're just like
oh if I can dial down the noise of the
social media gurus or if I can believe
that man if I just go learn on YouTube
learn the skill I can go apply for that
job and make double what I'm making now
yeah but people have just had the belief
beat out of them they're just hopeless
they're cynical and they think like this
is the world we live in the economy and
the Boomers and I talk about that in in
the first chapter of the book I lay out
every single objection and excuse that
we could point fingers at and it feels
good it felt good to write it it was
cathartic I was like yeah man the
housing Market's insane and college
tuition's out of control and the fed and
Congress and the guy in the White House
and it at the end of the day it was just
when I point back at me it was like oh
gosh not me not me not me back to the
other stuff right right it's not fun to
pull up that Financial mirror to go like
okay even if you're not the entire
problem you are the entire solution yeah
and we know that like forgiveness from
the government it's probably not going
to happen like inflation is not a dial I
can control but what I can control is
I'm going to do that side hustle to get
out of debt for the next two years yeah
and then I'm going to bust my butt and
save up and I'm going to get married and
we're going to combine finances and now
we have two incomes and now we're going
to make a little more progress and a
little more progress and it might take
you a decade and you wanted it to take a
year and we know most people they
overestimate what they can accomplish in
a year underestimate what they can
accomplish in a decade that was my story
yep didn't happen over night it took 10
years for some people it'll take 20 y
That's okay run your own race cuz when
you run other people's race there's no
Finish Line that's the problem with this
kind of comparison mindset of like well
John's you see the kind of car he has
and the kind of house he has dude like
he doesn't pay your bills right you
don't know what he's going through yeah
and so it gave me great peace and for
that person who's feels stuck to just go
all right I'm not going to compare
myself I'm going to tunnel vision and go
what is the right Next Step for me and I
I think that's the reason that's so
important is um
strangely and it's weird to admit this I
when I spent all those years working in
higher education with this with students
it was the conversation was so much in
my lap what can I solve for them um
bring me your challenges and I'll solve
them for you and there is a part of that
right part of my job was to teach them
what options were and not make that
happen but it was it was an eye
openening moment for me a few years ago
when I was sitting some somewhere saying
hey every time I've sat down with a
family who's about to lose a child every
time I've sat down with someone who just
lost a loved one every time I've sat
down with somebody who was marginalized
because of Any number of reasons
society's kicked them to the margins so
we don't want you
here we I always sit in those moments
and they're heavy and they're dark and
they are filled with tears and it could
be two hours it could be two months it
could be two years of conversations we
always land on the same question what
are you going to do now and it was when
I sat here with this money thing because
I was always for 20 years I've been
wondering what Washington's going to do
about this stuff and I knew I know Dave
Ramsey principles and all but I kept
saying what's the right monetary policy
and what's this and this you were coming
at it intellectually right instead of
looking in the mirror going okay dude
this is the way this is right now what
are we going to do the house is on fire
and it's like sitting there and watching
it burn and being like when is a fire
department getting here at some point
you got to go hey they're not coming
they're not coming or they're going to
get here it's going be too late get the
family out of here let's get all our our
stuff out of here and so I think it's
important for people to know in this
book you a walk
through we call them traps and stuff and
you and I laugh about it because we live
in this world but I think it's like I
have family members that genuinely had
never heard that a credit score is a
scam they didn't know that that
generally did thought they were missing
something when they didn't understand
crypto like I'm behind or that they
don't have a rental property that they
have are 100% leveraged on so they feel
behind and they're just screwed yeah
they feel completely hosed and so a you
walk through all these excus all all the
things that were told that aren't true
and then you walk through what I think
is more important is a plan here's what
you do man and I wish it was more
complicated than that here's a plan and
it's not hard it's hard but it's not
hard right simple but not not hard right
yeah in in chap chapter n is where we
move from the system to Breaking Free
from the system so it's chained to the
system here's all the things that you're
chained to and then I'm going to show
you how to break free and so I talk
about budgeting is freedom spending is
self-control margin is breathing room
savings is peace debt is a thief wealth
is patience and my favorite is
generosity is Joy yeah is what the whole
thing kind of points to and in the book
like the fruits of the spirit is the
verse I use on the on the flap on the
title page because truthfully I feel
like that's what we're all striving for
we want peace and joy and self-control
that's what we're aiming at and money is
just an obstacle instead of a tool to
help us get there so if we can remove
that obstacle and transform it into a
tool to where we go we don't have to
worry about money we got time now we can
connect with our we can build those
relationships that were broken and you
also loosen the chains
of your employer running your life other
companies running your life even in some
ways not legally but the government
running you're like like we're going to
raise interest okay I don't borrow money
so
yeah when Dave Ramsey has a 0% interest
rate cuz he doesn't have a mortgage he's
not as concerned or when they say what's
your credit score he's like I don't I
haven't looked it 30 years I don't know
and I just don't care right finally we
have to solve this important thing then
we got to
go there's a Reddit Thread about this
there's a great conspiracy across the
country we need to clear up let's do
it are we actually friends oh
gosh I ask myself every day honestly I
think it
changes I think we it's one of those we
love each other we don't like each other
I don't love you I think I like you but
I don't it goes you like me I love you
it causes some tension causes a lot of
on the show and here's the backstory uh
John is mean to me I'm going put that in
air quotes cuz I've actually been
bullied and uh in in my previous life
when I was a kid what Jon does I is a
defense mechanism that I see through
instantly oh okay you see me as a threat
that is correct my masculinity is a
threat to your is well you have a
perfectly groomed beard and I just can't
grow facial hair so instantly I'm
waiting for you to just come out with
this you have uh you have biohacked your
eyes with these devices called glasses I
don't have those I just you have perfect
vision F I just I have blurry vision
it's fine fine but the truth is uh I
think I'm your friend I'm your friend I
think you're my friend we text each
other outside of work you send me
articles that you find interesting I
pushed your Tesla down the highway when
it ran out of batteries that's a true
friend that's what friends do so on the
show we're not good at showing it
truthfully you know what I mean I like
it we're not good at showing each other
affection live on air but I like it that
way and it's kind of a bit too like when
I'm like I'm here with my best friend in
the whole world John delone and you're
like we're not friends exactly that to
me is a bit and uh but they see us at
the blink182 show singing our hearts out
rocking out together see so I think that
I think that squelches it oh we're going
to edit that part out we're not going to
let this part go live okay cool hey
Breaking Free from broke George camel's
new book thanks for writing this thanks
for the support man you you get
mentioned at least three times and I
apologize I do do call you a mediocre
guitar player in the book I think
mediocre is um but it's compared to
slash it's very generous it's compared
to SL I'm not even mediocre but I do
have some great quotes from you that are
very helpful and there's so much that
aligns when it comes to what you're
doing and what I'm doing in the money
space we both want people to solve for
freedom and I know this book is going to
help you do that with finances so thanks
for helping me spread the word you're
awesome BR thanks you're a great friend
and I agree to
disagree hey what's up delone here
listen you and me and everybody else on
the planet has felt anxious or burned
out or chronically stressed at some
point in my new book building a
non-anxious life you'll learn the six
daily choices that you can make to get
rid of your anxious feelings and be able
to better respond to whatever life
throws at you so you can build a more
peaceful nonanxious life get your copy
today at john.com
all right we are back and that was my
friend George Campbell in that last
segment talking about his brand new book
Breaking Free from
broke if you're struggling with money
and it's hard to let me just say this
way it's hard to have a good marriage
and you're broke if you're fighting
about money it's hard to um be a parent
that can plug in with your kids it's
hard to um be good out on The Dating
Market I hate to use that language but
it is what it is um it's tough to do
just about anything when your body's
telling you you're not safe because of
money go pick up GE book Breaking Free
from broke it's out tomorrow everywhere
we'll link to it in the show notes you
can go anywhere and buy it um but it's
good go pick it up go pick it up and as
we wrap up today's show George mentioned
a friend of ours Jillian Edwards song
that he plays for his sweet sweet baby
um every single night and that he sings
he doesn't sing very well but he sings
he at least he's a dad that sings to his
kid song's called Meadow by the great
Jillian Edwards and it goes like this
your love is a meadow meow I'm free to
run around in Barefoot on the soil I'm
feeling like a child again what if
there's nothing to be afraid of I think
you're closer than my blood what if
you're in the lines on my hand I think
your heart is beating in my chest I need
to I need only to breathe in your
love I thought you wrote this Kelly When
you put this on my Christmas card and
I'm kind of heartbroken that Jillian
Edwards wrote
it h
real cool love you guys stay in school
don't do drugs
bye